hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I'm John Humphrey today we are gonna
watch the season 5 trailer for a show I
actually follow in John follows to
Silicon Valley
this time TJ Miller will not be
returning oh that's a bummer he was my
fav but before we do that I want to give
a shout out to today's video sponsor
that is the Stardust app the main
company that we like to work with we
have over a hundred posts on the
Stardust app currently right now what
this app allows you to do is through
30-second reviews or reactions for any
TV show film or trailer we'd love love
using the app Tyrone Magnus is on the
app now the flick picks on the app the
schmoes know Jeremy John's Wendy the
whole bunch of people but if we are the
first ones to tell you about this app
you should follow us first download the
link in the description box follow us
first they know were the ones who sent
you guys this trust me we post regularly
on it if there's movies or TV shows that
we're not covering on YouTube your best
believe that we'll be talking about it
on that app and by the way quick mention
we're starting to TV show reactions I
shot a few already right now we're
putting up the full length TV show
reactions over our patreon to keep a
lookout for that or check out our
patreon in the meantime
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what boy oh boy man he's trying to get
that Pied Piper working right now one
one step closer yeah that's all those
refrigerators we never talked about this
show on the channel I want to tell you
guys I love this show because coming
from a background with doing YouTube for
a few years now getting a better grasp
of how the internet works and while we
don't develop apps there's so much that
I feel we can relate to on such a
personal level of behind-the-scenes of
everything of how this all works I
thought it really clicks with the show a
lot a lot of our efforts in trying to
get this old channel afloat it felt very
much yeah into the kinds of struggles
not not yet not the same things but the
kinds of struggles they face in this
yeah and with the way how YouTube is
constantly reworking itself and just
changing it algorithm and all these
things called pocalypse the way things
constantly change and then we have to
like readjust to the changes and then
figured out then rebuild and a lot of
other things that's why I really love
this show cuz it makes me feel not so
alone in the world usually when I talk
to other youtubers it's a lot of
complaining about YouTube here is like
okay well this is kind of the common
thing about business in general and it's
a common thing about the Tagus is the
internet world this makes me feel really
good just watching Hendricks struggle
and suffer and in the last season he
like really went to a super dark place
that the show got way darker and more
serious than its ever
well yeah because so much of the theme
of season 4 is about everybody getting a
bit too big for their britches and gonna
have ego maniacal and everybody falls
from that grace and sick of struggling
and trying to create shortcuts and doing
whatever you can even if it's you know
morally wrong or illegal oh yeah yeah
that becomes a big debate later on in
the season when a lot of things start to
change and like season four wasn't
necessarily my leg is dark for sure yeah
and I'm curious to see where this is
gonna take it cuz you know now that
they're actually got an office and a
company go yeah you're probably gonna
get some new characters too which kind
of softens the blow of losing it
Erlik yeah way it's like I'm wondering
now we're probably gonna get some more
regulars well shake even though Erlich
was my favorite one to watch because he
was the funniest one at the end of the
day in terms of the story of this all he
is the least essential between the whole
team because what made him funny was
that he wasn't that essential and yeah
it was part of like the running gag and
and the way they left off with him like
it's a bummer to have that happen but at
the same time like yeah it seems like
what would how do you wait for him to go
I just hope this show doesn't get
repetitive now because yeah you know
with Belson being the head of hooli
again and then though they got Pied
Piper they've had an office before
they've had the company booming before I
really hope this show is able to do some
new things right now because of course
it's easier trailers is exciting that
it's coming back right now I'm like
looking this man I don't really know
what different things they can do maybe
they'll get some wins this time cuz they
they're usually just struggling and
that's part of what makes this show so
enticing is how much they struggle after
a while it does start to feel like this
is this is getting a bit repetitive hey
you know they definitely need to spice
things up for sure and that's why at
least this trailer didn't really give me
a whole lot of new stuff but that was
one of the biggest things that struck me
is like at least there's chance for for
new blood and and they're on a new scale
of their business and Jared's back and
Jared's back thought Jared quit buddy
Zach well you know Richard Richard
realigned himself and now I think
they're free amarak together yeah yeah I
definitely agree that like I love the
show but I do think especially now that
Season five has happened that made some
drastic changes and those with its
darkest season for was feel like now is
a good time to shake things up because I
mean this shows been a hit
and the only way for it to keep on it
seems like there's a long way for Pied
Piper to go so I hope they can find ways
to make that narrative interesting yeah
because I really think this show can
only probably go one or two more seasons
I don't think it should go anything past
that to be honest yeah unless they find
some real new topic to focus on but yeah
if we're just following this one
trajectory I feel like yeah it should
wrap up at some point maybe it'll end
with Hendricks switching to Verizon yeah
yeah Verizon commercials were connected
it's foreshadowing the future we didn't
realize we're watching flash-forwards on
TV this whole time yeah I mean he's
basically playing a less awkward version
but are you excited for Silicon Valley
to be coming back I am I can't wait to
watch this again it's a great show to
eat my eggs to and watch in the morning
you can subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification Bell to get
notified anytime one of our videos is up
and make sure to download and follow us
first on the Stardust app like I said we
have over a hundred posts on there so we
post regularly better believe it and
last mention we are doing TV show
reactions right now we remain ly
sticking to the shows that we want to
watch but you know who knows maybe we'll
do Silicon Valley shake it